Depuis les dimanches derniers, on a commencé à considérer ce passage du verset 26 jusqu'à la fin du chapitre 8 d'Actes.
L'une des raisons, c'était car j'ai été invité pendant mes vacances au Brésil à prêcher sur ce texte et j'étais tellement béni.
Mais aussi car on s'approchait de la rentrée et c'est toujours important quand on s'approche de la rentrée car c'est très naturel pour nous dans ce monde et parfois très positif.
de renouveler nos résolutions mais malheureusement parfois nos résolutions se portent beaucoup plus vers les aspects très temporels de cette vie.
La carrière, la vocation, les changements qu'on aimerait avoir.
Par contre c'est un rappel, ces passages du fait que l'identité principale de tous les chrétiens c'est que Dieu a fait de nous ses témoins.
Et là c'est une question pas de faire, il y a aussi des choses que nous faisons dans cette direction, mais c'est une question d'être.
On est revenu au chapitre 1 d'Actes pour lire la promesse du Christ juste avant son ascension,
qui disait que l'Église recevrait les Saint-Esprit et le Christ va manifester dans ces passages l'un des rôles principaux du Saint-Esprit.
Donc il dit, vous recevrez les Saint-Esprits et vous serrez mes témoins.
Les rôles principaux du Saint-Esprit, c'est d'un étant, la troisième personne de la Trinité,
d'un étant l'Esprit des dieux lui-même, l'Esprit du Seigneur Jésus-Christ lui-même,
au moment où on se convertit, c'est le Saint-Esprit qui fait le travail de nous présenter Christ à nos yeux spirituels.
Ce qui fait que la conversion véritable soit une rencontre réelle et expérimentale avec le Seigneur Jésus-Christ, notre Sauveur.
Voilà pourquoi c'est impossible que celui qui s'est converti ne soit pas un témoin,
car le témoin c'est celui qui contemple avec ses propres yeux un fait, une personne.
Donc si nous sommes témoins du Christ et de son Évangile, c'est car on a compris que dans l'histoire,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ a accompli son œuvre, des saluts, des rédemptions, mais plus que ça,
il s'est présenté à nous-mêmes comme notre Sauveur personnel par la présence de son Esprit.
Donc, nos enfants élevés à l'Église ont les privilèges d'avoir entendu des vrais témoins,
ses parents, chrétiens véritables.
La vérité à propos de l'Évangile.
Mais ils ne deviennent pas des vrais croyants ou des vrais témoins
jusqu'à ce que les Saint-Esprits de Dieu ouvrent dans leur vie
pour que Christ se présente par son Esprit comme leur Sauveur personnel.
Voilà pourquoi Dieu n'a pas de nouveaux, Dieu n'a pas de petits-enfants, Dieu n'a qu'il y a des enfants.
Une personne peut rentrer dans la machine de l'Église et avoir la capacité, comme un perroquet, de répéter les choses qu'ils ont entendues.
Mais un témoin, c'est celui qui a contemplé des premières mains le Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et ça, c'est le travail principal du Saint-Esprit.
Apporter chez un chrétien la fraîcheur de la présence du Christ, de la connaissance du Christ, de la joie de salut,
et nous faire déborder de cette tardiesse, d'avoir contemplé face à face notre Seigneur et Sauveur dans la puissance du Saint-Esprit.
Et donc, quel est l'intérêt d'Actes quand on arrive au chapitre 8 ?
C'est d'après avoir contemplé la persécution en Jérusalem,
Luc, un médecin, un rechercheur, de manière très intentionnelle,
va démontrer comment cette promesse du chapitre 1 est en train de s'accomplir.
C'est quelque chose qui concernait la première génération des disciples.
Et Actes n'est pas un livre qui est censé s'arrêter dans l'histoire qu'il raconte dans le Nouveau Testament.
En termes canoniques, il est conclu, fini, que ce soit clair.
Et l'objectif d'Actes, c'est de présenter où l'identité de chaque chrétien dans toute l'histoire de l'Église se retrouve
dans cette œuvre qui Christ a promis, qui allait durer jusqu'à son retour.
Et donc, quand on va lire la Bible, quand on va lire Actes,
on n'est pas à la recherche des petites directions pour nos ambitions très personnelles,
très privées pour la vie de tous les jours.
C'est pour nous rappeler que ces livres sont en train d'enflammer nos cœurs
pour qu'on comprenne quelle est notre position dans ces plans,
qui est l'œuvre numéro un des Jeux jusqu'au retour du Christ.
Ce qui donne le plus grand sens à notre existence,
c'est de participer à l'évangélisation, à l'avancement du Christ,
les seuls royaumes qui vont surmonter tous les empires,
et tous les royaumes, et toutes les nations du monde.
Donc, Christ a fait de nous des ambassadeurs, des témoins.
Et un acte, c'est exactement ça qu'il veut mettre en lumière.
Acte 1, Jérusalem, Jérusalem, Jérusalem, Jérusalem, Jérusalem.
Acte 8, là où nous sommes, c'est un Philippe qui s'élève après la persécution de Jérusalem,
avec les chrétiens laïcs qui sont éparpillés par la Judée,
et Philippe qui sera introduit en Saint-Marie,
et qui va toucher la vie des séonucs éthiopiens,
qui représentent lui-même les débuts de l'évangélisation des extrémités de la terre.
Et donc, pour nous, la vérité centrale qu'on a commencé à considérer,
c'est que
les buts, ou l'un des buts principaux
de tous les vrais chrétiens,
c'est
d'être un témoin du Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
On a deux grands privilèges dans cette vie.
Les premiers,
être l'objet du salut,
et par là, être réconcilié avec Dieu,
et donc avoir accès
irrestrict
à la contemplation de la gloire de Dieu,
et la réjouissance de sa gloire,
prendre plaisir en lui.
Et le deuxième privilège immédiatement,
un privilège exclusif pour cette vie,
car quand on partira à la gloire,
c'est fini l'opportunité pour nous de participer à cette œuvre.
Mais c'est le privilège
d'être utilisé
par Christ
envers la promotion
de la plus grande joie
que l'humanité puisse expérimenter.
La joie d'être
délivré
d'une souffrance
éternelle à l'enfer.
Et c'est la plus grande remontée,
car c'est la joie d'être réconcilié
avec la source suprême de bonheur.
Il n'y a aucune vocation
qu'on puisse se consacrer dans cette vie
qui puisse nous donner
un sens de signification,
des pertinences,
des buts pour vivre,
qui est tout simplement
à soumettre notre identité en tant qu'évangéliste,
en tant que témoin.
et quand on contemple Philippe
dans ses passages,
on est devant
une personne qui était
un évangéliste exceptionnel,
mais nous sommes aussi devant
une personne qui représente
pour nous tous
un modèle d'évangélisation.
Et donc,
la question qu'on a posée au texte,
c'est comment
l'exemple de Philippe
sert des modèles pour nous,
pour qu'on soit des bons témoins,
des témoins bibliques,
pour qu'on soit
enflammés envers l'évangélisation,
et que ça soit la vérité
centrale,
la plus importante
à propos de notre identité.
Qui sujet ?
Je ne réponds pas
en commençant par ma profession,
mes origines,
mes diplômes,
mes dégrés,
ma classe sociale.
Je suis
un ambassadeur
du roi des dieux,
je suis un représentant
du Christ,
je suis un témoin
du Seigneur Jésus.
Ok ?
Et donc,
la première réponse
qu'on retrouve ici,
c'est que comme Philippe,
le Seigneur Jésus
a fait de nous
ces messagers
qui sont soumis
à sa direction
et à la direction
de son esprit.
Donc,
quand on va
les premiers,
quand on a considéré
les premiers versets
de ces passages,
on va retrouver
le Seigneur Jésus
dans son trône de gloire
après son ascension
qui envoie un ange
avec une mission
très particulière
qui est de
rediriger
l'œuvre missionnaire
de cet évangéliste.
Et donc là,
déjà,
on voit combien
revêtu d'autorité
est la tâche missionnaire.
Que les Christ
envoient
de son trône
des gloires,
d'autorité,
un ange
pour que
ses témoins sur terre
soient mobilisés
à se soumettre
à sa direction.
Philippe est présenté
dans la Bible
comme un homme
rempli de saint-esprit
et on a considéré
que l'une des évidences
les plus puissantes
de quelqu'un
qui a soumis
au saint-esprit,
c'est tout simplement
l'obéissance.
Quelqu'un rempli
de saint-esprit
est soumis
aux ordres des dieux.
Ce n'est pas forcément
ceux qui peuvent
manifester
de manière très spectaculaire
plusieurs dons spectaculaires.
C'est la soumission
quand on revient
à l'Ephésien 4,
5 et 6.
À partir de là,
on voit qu'il est
promptement soumis
à l'ordre du Christ
pour devenir lui-même
à son tour
un ange
envers un perdu.
Et non seulement
c'est une soumission
prompte
car il s'élève
et part
donc BC 27
mais c'était aussi
une soumission coûteuse
contraire au glamour
et qui révèle
un amour
très important au perdu
car il sortira
d'un ministère
très réussi
en Samarie
avec des multitudes
qui sont baptisées
et converties
avec des manifestations
des miracles
pour partir
envers les déserts
en faisant un voyage
coûteux
pour toucher
la vie et l'âme
de cet homme
qui était seul
au désert
mais qui était
très important
pour les saints
Jésus-Christ
qui était dans sa gloire.
C'est aussi
une soumission
toujours très avantageuse
car on voit
que les moments
où Philippe
va rencontrer
Léonuc
c'est exactement
dans les timings
parfaits
où Léonuc
est en train
de lire
verset
voilà pourquoi
nous devons
voir cette
sensibilité
à la direction
du Saint-Esprit
et cette sensibilité
à l'usage
que les seigneurs
font même
des anges
qui sont des ministres
qui sont là
pour nous aider
à nous mobiliser
envers les salutes
de perdus
et même si nous pouvons
être
très suspicieux
envers les abus
de certains
siècles évangéliques
qui vont présenter
ces interactions
avec les anges
ou ces interactions
subjectives
avec les saints-esprits
malgré ces abus
nous ne pouvons
jamais supprimer
la réalité
de ces interactions
entre la troisième
personne de la Trinité
qui habite en nous
et les rôles principaux
qu'il y a là
qui a des faits
des témoins
du Christ
nous sommes constamment
sous son influence
la question c'est
est-ce que nous sommes
facilement soumis
à sa direction
est-ce que nous sommes
suffisamment sensibles
à sa direction
ou est-ce que nous sommes
plutôt en train
de vouloir
les faire taire
et mener
notre propre vie
idolâtre
le deuxième aspect
qu'on a considéré
c'est que comme Philippe
nous devons participer
de manière ordinaire
et intentionnelle
à la grande commission
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
même si un ange
est apparu
à Philippe
pour faire
une légère déviation
des cours des routes
Philippe
il était déjà
en train d'exercer
de manière très ordinaire
l'évangélisation
il était de manière
très intentionnelle
consacrant sa vie
à faire
que l'évangile
avance
dans les directions
des peuples non-atants
il était
avant
de penser
à être
une bénédiction
aux extrémités
de la terre
il était déjà
une bénédiction
là où il était
il montre
avoir une connaissance
suffisamment
équipée
pour partager
l'évangile
avec clarté
il montre
avoir
une vie d'intimité
avec Dieu
et son esprit
une vie de prière
suffisamment évidente
pour être
une bénédiction
là où il était
il était déjà
en train de consacrer
le mieux de son temps
à développer
un bagage
missionnaire
pour qu'il puisse
progresser
en efficacité
et en général
ceux qui ont
les plus grands
privilèges
avec
ces aspects
plus
subjectifs
intimes
et spectaculaires
avec le Saint-Esprit
sont ceux qui sont
plutôt dans la vangarde
de l'évangélisation
ceux qui sont
les plus actifs
dans l'évangélisation
et donc
il était fidèle
dans l'ordinaire
il était
intentionnel
stratégique
il faisait
des sacrifices
à un moment donné
il a même dû
courir
pour accompagner
ses chariots
et donc
c'est la leçon
pour nous
nous devons
considérer
l'importance
d'être déjà
en bénédiction locale
au sein de la famille
avant de considérer
la possibilité
d'être une bénédiction
globale
et nous devons
apprendre
à reconnaître
selon la Bible
qu'en général
les références
des relations
extraordinaires
ou subjectives
avec le Saint-Esprit
sont toujours
dans la Bible
pas dans la direction
à nouveau
désolé pour l'exemple
de nous présenter
un ange
avec
un plateau d'or
qui nous donne
la clé
de la maison
promise
mais
en général
c'est lié
à l'évangélisation
globale
à quelqu'un
qui a perdu
à un corneille
qui a besoin
d'entendre
l'évangile
à un eunuque
perdu
au désert
à un homme européen
qui apparaît
à Paul
pour qu'il fasse
aussi sa déviation
des routes
mais c'est important
de reconnaître
que
toutes manifestations
du Saint-Esprit
seront parfaitement
en accord
car c'est lui-même
qui a inspiré
la parole de Dieu
donc seront toujours
parfaitement en harmonie
avec la parole de Dieu
et donc
Philippe avait déjà écouté
aller prêcher
l'évangile
à toutes les nations
c'est ce qu'il était
en train de faire
vous serez
mettez-moi
à Jérusalem
etc.
il savait
où il devrait aller
et donc il faut avoir
cette sensibilité
pour raisonner
de manière
très intentionnelle
et stratégique
comment ma vie
aujourd'hui
peut atteindre
son plus grand
potentiel
pour l'évangile
et l'évangile
est-ce que c'est
le temps de me préparer
et commencer déjà
dans certaines mesures
à exercer
une évangile
comment mon église
même s'est suture
car nous
intentionnellement
on a qu'il y ait
deux réunions
pendant la semaine
on ne veut pas
attirer les personnes
pour des événements
au sein de l'église
on veut vous donner
du temps
suffisant
pour être équipé
ici
et pour exercer
vos ministères
d'évangélisation
d'être intentionnel
dans l'organisation
de vos agendas
d'inviter des amis
non-chrétiens
une fois par mois
peut-être
mais d'être
tout simplement
intentionnel
dans la manière
dont vous allez
faire l'évangélisation
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer aussi
la force
de la jeunesse
Étienne
et Philippe
qui apparemment
ici étaient
entre ses 25 ans
35 ans
Philippe plus tard
après 20 ans
aura 4 filles
il sera
à ses arrêts
avec une vie
plus stable
moins de mouvement
et comme disait
JC Wright
dans son livre
sur l'exhortation
aux jeunes chrétiens
de faire
le mieux
usage
de vos efforts
aujourd'hui
pendant que vous êtes
en pleine force
je me rappelle
quand j'étais appelé
au ministère
que l'une des choses
que j'appréciais
le plus
dans les prédicateurs
que j'ai trouvé
les plus bénissants
c'était la manière
dont ils avaient
la capacité
pas d'exagérer
dans les exemples
dans toutes les prédications
mais tout simplement
la quantité
d'exemples
des évangélisations
qu'ils avaient à partager
les exemples
des vies
des conseils
les privilèges
d'avoir pu vivre
pour l'évangile
suffisamment
en consacrant
des temps
qui leur permettaient
déjà
de voir
quelques résultats
et à nous
d'avoir
ces mêmes expériences
les plus tôt
que possible
de consacrer
nos vies
les plus tôt
que possible
nos meilleures forces
les plus tôt
que possible
les dynamismes
de l'apôtre Paul
détiennent
les dynamismes
de Philippe
qui nous montre
que c'est impossible
de perdre du temps
si nous sommes en train
d'investir nos vies
envers
les implications
éternelles
et donc ici
c'est un Philippe
qui était très stratégique
très intentionnel
qui était conscient
de l'importance
de consacrer sa vie
à cette tâche
et donc aujourd'hui
on va rentrer
dans un troisième point
et c'est possiblement
le point
les plus importants
car si toutes ces choses
font partie
d'une évangélisation
biblique
les prochains points
nous parlent
non seulement
du commandement
des dieux
envers l'évangélisation
l'importance
de cette œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
chez les prédicateurs
ou l'évangéliste
et chez celui
qui entend l'évangile
mais ça parle
du moment
proprement
dit
pardon
du partage
de l'évangile
l'évangélisation
tout comme
aujourd'hui
on réduit
l'évangélisation
à la distribution
d'un tract
à la présentation
des quatre lois spirituelles
au parcours
ou à notre parcours
bon des méthodes
et des outils
qui peuvent avoir
leur lieu
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
qu'ici nous sommes
devant
un modèle
biblique
d'interaction
organique
envers l'évangélisation
une interaction
très personnelle
d'âme
à âme
et qui n'a pas
une formule
définie
préconçue
et donc
comme Philippe
nous devons
être capables
à proclamer
les Christs
selon
l'écriture
nous devons
être capables
et toujours
prêts
à proclamer
Christ
selon l'écriture
quand on lit
les versets 30
à 36
nous allons
réunir ensemble
Philippe
accru
et entendit
l'éthiopien
qui lisait
les prophètes
les œils
il lui dit
comprends-tu
ce que tu lis
il répondit
comment
les pourrais-je
si quelqu'un
ne m'est guide
et il invita
Philippe à monter
et à s'asseoir
avec lui
les passages
d'écriture
qu'il lisait
étaient
celui-ci
il a été mené
comme une brée
vie à la boucherie
et comme un agneau moué
devant celui qui l'étend
il la pond vers la bouche
dans son humiliation
son jugement
a été
lévé
et sa postérité
qui la dépendra
car sa vie
a été
rétranchée
de la terre
et Léonuc
dit à Philippe
je t'ai pris
de qui les prophètes
parlent-ils ainsi
est-ce de lui-même
ou de quelqu'un autre
alors Philippe
ouvrant la bouche
et commençant
par ses passages
lui annonça
la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
et comme ils continuaient
sur leur chemin
ils rencontrèrent
l'eau
ça va être ici
pour l'instant
et donc nous allons
analyser ici
ce qui est une évangélisation
biblique
efficace
et le premier élément
qu'on peut remarquer ici
c'est que
l'évangélisation efficace
est sensible
à un intérêt réel
envers Dieu
donc ici
nous ne sommes pas
devant des méthodologies
formules
des gâteaux
nous sommes devant
une description biblique
Luc à nouveau
en écrivant
acte
était intentionnel
à nous donner
un peu l'arrière-plan
de ses tenues
et c'était un homme
qui avait
un intérêt
positif
restez avec moi
un intérêt positif
envers
ce qui devrait être
la bonne religion
il était
un prosélyte
les plus probablement
il était
allé
à Jérusalem
pour la Pentecôte
il venait
de l'Ethiopie
et déjà
ça parle
énormément
du contexte
de cet homme
il était un homme
très élevé
dans la société
juste au-dessus
de la reine
de l'Ethiopie
il était
un eunuque
un homme
qui a voulu
prouver
son allégeance
à tel point
de ses castrés
et qui gérait
tous les biens
un trésorier
la vie des cours
il la connaissait
très bien
il réjouissait
d'énormément
des privilèges
mais d'avoir
gagné
les mondes
n'était pas
suffisant pour lui
il mettait
en question
l'aspect
divin
du roi
car dans cette culture
les rois
ils étaient
comme un dieu
et ça parle beaucoup
de l'inversion
des valeurs
et l'omission
de la place
des responsabilités
d'un homme
dans cette nation
dans cette culture
car
les rois
réjouissaient
du privilège
d'être traités
comme un dieu
ou un demi-dieu
et toute la gestion
du roi homme
était sous
l'entendance
de son épouse
et donc
reine des candas
ici c'est plutôt
un titre
et donc
ses trésoriers
il était là
comme un petit
Joseph
dans l'Ethiopie
comme Joseph
il était
pour l'Egypte
et malgré
tous les privilèges
qu'il a pu vivre
dans sa vie
il n'était pas
satisfait
c'est intéressant
le John
il va évoquer
même
l'intentionnalité
avec laquelle
cet homme
a pris la route
du désert
qui n'était pas
la plus courte
pour rentrer
chez lui
il devrait être
une évidence
de sa frustration
non seulement
avec une vie
très aisée
mais avec
un espoir
qui n'a pas été
comblé
lorsqu'il est parti
envers
la bonne religion
le problème
c'est que
la bonne religion
était très corrompue
il n'a pas trouvé
paon
dans la maison
du paon
il est parti
vers Jérusalem
dans une génération
qui était
aussi dans
l'attente
des satisfactions
temporelles
qu'attendait
un Jésus
militaire
un Messie
pour que la
prospérité
terrestre
d'Israël
soit restaurée
peut-être
des promesses
d'une prospérité
sur terre
qu'il connaissait
très bien
et qu'il ne manquait
pas
mais son problème
était dans
l'autre niveau
et c'est intéressant
car
l'intentionalité
biblique
de nous montrer
cet arrière-plan
tout comme
il nous montre
aussi dans les cas
de la femme samaritaine
une personne
qui a beau
essayer
de trouver
des plaisirs
dans un certain
domaine
qu'il ne trouvait
pas
et un homme
qui malgré
tout ça
essaye de persévérer
non seulement
dans la religion
dans les temples
à Jérusalem
ou dans les possibles
synagogues
de la diaspora
proche de chez lui
mais il était
avec la Bible
ouverte lui-même
il était
en train
de lire la Bible
et ces sensibilités
elles sont très importantes
car nous devons chercher
à partager l'évangile
en toute occasion
mais nous devons aussi
avoir la sensibilité
de percevoir
lorsque les personnes
sont véritablement ouvertes
ou complètement
servent
à l'évangile
et quand il s'approche
il a la Bible
ouverte
et ça
c'est très important
pour qu'on comprenne
deux choses
la première
la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
de chaque individu
je me rappelle très bien
ma mère
elle mettait avant
sa conversion
avant ma conversion
de manière assez
superstitieuse
peut-être
l'Epsom 23
sous la vitre
d'une table
dans ma chambre
donc j'ai mémorisé
mais j'ai jamais vu
l'implication
envers
la rédemption
trouvée en Christ
et quand j'ai pas fait des fois
pour essayer de lire la Bible
car on avait quand même
une Bible aussi un peu
superstitieuse à la maison
je me rappelle
d'avoir un dictionnaire
à côté
toujours
donc quelle est la leçon ici
cet homme
il était à Jérusalem
dans les temples
et maintenant
il lit la Bible
dans un des textes
qui parle
les plus
et les plus
clairement
quelqu'un a déjà dit
c'est l'évangile
selon Esaïe
sur Christ
un Christ
qui venait
d'être exécuté
et lui
qui le plus probablement
a été exposé
à ce que se passe
en acte 2
toutes les nations
rassemblées
pour la Pentecôte
et les témoignages
puissants
des apôtres
dans plusieurs langues
qui essayent
de nous expliquer
cet événement
qui a été
la crucifixion
du Christ
quel texte
pouvait faire
le plus
la liaison
si ce n'est
ces textes-là
par contre
la Bible
elle peut faire
énormément
des biens
car nous croyons
nous chrétiens
nous croyons
dans ce qu'on appelle
la loi de la nature
c'est-à-dire
comme nous sommes
tous créatures
des dieux
tous les êtres humains
ont une capacité
essentielle
même si corrompue
de raisonner
et de reconnaître
les lois des dieux
les lois générales
des dieux
dans la moralité
dans la conscience
voilà pourquoi
les dix commandements
même si c'est la
concrétisation
externe
de cette loi
essentielle
c'est une loi
qu'on va y trouver
même si
corrompue
et cautérisée
dans la conscience
de tous les êtres humains
donc toutes les sociétés
et donc on peut
s'approcher
de la bible
et tirer
et comprendre
plusieurs aspects
et tirer du profit
pour la vraie vie
des applications
même politiques
par contre
une expérience
salvatrice
avec la parole
des dieux
personne ne peut produire
pas ses propres efforts
la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
elle
son point de départ
et c'est ça qui est
très intéressant
dans ces dialogues
bêtes qu'on a parfois
avec la position arménienne
la question c'est
pourquoi vous partez
pour faire
l'évangélisation
si c'est dieux
qui doit tout faire
et la réponse
elle est
tellement claire ici
et la question c'est
l'opposé
on croit
à la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
car il n'y a aucun sens
pour partir
essayer de faire
de l'évangélisation
si nous ne croyons pas
que Dieu opère
car un homme
avec une sincérité
honnête
pour chercher
Dieu
n'a pas
la capacité
de les trouver
toutes seules
même avec la bible
ouverte
si les saints esprits
n'oppèrent pas
la rémunération
et plus
il a plu
à Dieu
de manière générale
car plusieurs personnes
peuvent se convertir
tout simplement
à lire la bible
mais il a plu à Dieu
de faire
que l'évangélisation
ait lieu
donc Dieu
a déterminé
que certains
seront sauvés
et Dieu
a déterminé
que certains
seront sauvés
par les moyens
de la proclamation
de l'évangile
donc nous faisons
l'évangélisation
car Dieu
a dévié
Philippe
d'un ministère
très prospère
à Samarie
pour aller rencontrer
un homme
avec la bible ouverte
afin qu'il explique
l'évangile
à cet homme
la souveraineté
des dieux
a fait que
les seigneurs
Jésus
dans sa position
suprême
d'autorité
envoie un ange
pour que cet ange
envoie un autre ange
maintenant
Philippe
comme un ambassadeur
envoyé
un homme seul
dans les déserts
avec la bible ouverte
la souveraineté
des dieux
est partout
dans cette évangélisation
mais elle est
surtout nécessaire
car la bible ouverte
à un homme aveugle
c'est comme un livre fermé
et donc
la sensibilité
envers l'intérêt
elle est tellement importante
pour nous
en tant qu'évangélistes
sortir de notre zone
de confort
changer complètement
notre agenda
Dieu nous a permis
pendant la journée
de trouver une occasion
qui s'ouvre pleinement
au partage de l'évangile
qu'est-ce que je ferais
de mes compromis
plus tard dans cette journée
on aime bien
mettre nos enfants libres
pour respecter aussi
leur fonctionnement
ils ont besoin
de dormir
d'être encadrés
quoi faire
lorsqu'il y a
les meilleures questions
théologiques
qu'il pose
c'est passe
pendant la nuit
qu'est-ce qui est
le plus important
à faire
on te répondra
à des mots
je me rappelle
pour H.E.R.
qui est parti
faire une conférence
très loin
de sa maison
et pendant qu'il prêche
il y a un homme
qui rentre
et qui ne fait
qu'elle pleurer
et donc à la fin
il a l'intérêt
de venir vers cet homme
et cet homme lui dit
j'ai une maladie terminale
le médecin m'a donné
trois mois de vie
mais je dois être honnête
je n'ai pas compris
les choses qu'il t'a dit ici
je comprends l'évangile
mais je ne vois pas
comment ces choses
s'appliquent à ma vie
pour H.E.R.
au même instant
a annulé son retour
ce qui implique
pour son épouse
aussi un sacrifice
avec ses petits-enfants
mais qui montre aussi
cette mentalité familiale
envers l'avancement
de l'heure
envers l'importance
des partages de l'évangile
il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on peut rattraper après
et parfois
le départage de l'évangile
on ne peut pas rattraper
plus tard
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
comment
Philippe a été sensible
et qu'il monte
dans ses charieux
pour partager l'évangile
à ses toits
donc une évangélisation
efficace
est sensible
à l'intérêt réel
d'une personne
envers Dieu
ensuite une évangélisation
efficace
est consciente
de l'importance
du rôle des dieux
ou les rôles
qui est Dieu assigné
pour nous
en tant qu'évangélistes
quand j'étais à l'école
je faisais beaucoup d'efforts
pour partager l'évangile
avec mes amis
mais il y avait
un collègue
un ami de l'école
qui n'était pas
très proche
et avec lui
c'était juste après
la conversion
je n'ai pas eu
l'occasion de partager
quelques semaines
ou quelques mois plus tard
il s'est suicidé
et j'ai eu un poids
énorme
plus tard
j'ai appris
à me reposer aussi
dans la souveraineté
des dieux
mais cette sensation
m'a toujours accompagné
d'avoir la conscience
que les âmes
qui croisent ma vie
peu importe en soi
peuvent être
peut-être
la seule opportunité
pour cette personne
de connaître l'évangile
et Dieu a décidé
qu'il sauvera
ces personnes
qui nous entourent
à travers les témoignages
des chrétiens
vous voyez l'importance
que nous avons
dans la société
l'importance
que nous avons
envers les âmes
qui nous entourent
et donc Philippe
il était conscient
qu'il devrait être
cet homme là
à qui cette question
qui est dans la tête
de toutes ces personnes
qui ont été
nos questions
elles-mêmes un jour
envers l'évangile
envers la foi
envers Dieu
mais c'est à nous
que cette question
est dirigée
des vrais êtres
dirigés
si du moins
on était disposés
c'est à nous
de diriger
plutôt cette question
comprends-tu
sectule
comprends-toi
l'évangile
et donc
le nuque aussi
nous montre
la conversion
de le nuque
que l'évangile
efficace
elle a lieu
dans une interaction
organique
car il faut faire
un éloge
à le nuque
avec son humilité
malgré sa position
sociale
très élevée
et c'est par là
je pense qu'on perçoit
les timings
les bons timings
pour partager
car on a des personnes
qui sont très
orgueilleuses
avec sa manière
de faire semblant
qu'ils sont en train
de poser des questions
mais en réalité
ils sont juste
en train de dévier
la conversation
et qu'ils sont arrogants
par rapport à ce qu'ils pensent
à propos de la foi
et parfois
ces mêmes personnes
ont des moments
de vulnérabilité
réelles
et c'est là
on doit maximiser
donc ici
cet homme
avec beaucoup
d'humilité
en posant
des bonnes questions
il dit
comment je pourrais
comprendre
si quelqu'un
ne me guide
et c'est la tristesse
d'une bonne majorité
même des croyants
dans la génération
qui ne se donnent
même pas
la possibilité
de se laisser guider
dans des enseignements
bibliques
car ils pensent
avoir déjà
tout compris
tout saisi
donc ici
il y a un besoin
envers les saluts
de tous les hommes
où nous tous
en tant que chrétiens
avons la capacité
et la responsabilité
de partager l'évangile
mais ici
il y a aussi
la position du maître
des hommes des dieux
appelés par dieux
qualifiés par dieux
pour expliquer
certains passages
de la bible
qui sont peut-être
parfois obscurs
ou pour corriger
des habitudes
qui nous avons
d'église dans le jour
qui ne sont pas
justifiables
par la parole de dieux
et pour nous faire
revenir en compréhension
même envers l'église
qui soit biblique
et on doit faire
un éloge à Philippe
avec cette sensibilité
et ces temps
qu'il a consacré
pour s'asseoir
et pour interagir
et le Luc qui vient
dire à Philippe
je t'ai pris
de qui
les prophètes
partent-ils ainsi
de lui-même
ou de quelqu'un d'autre
une interaction
organique
réelle
d'âme
à âme
par
d'avoir
électrisé
et coupabilisé
par mon manque
d'activité
dans l'évaluation
parfois
par une église
qui ne veut
que faire grandir
en termes numériques
et qui essaye
de nous obliger
et nous formater
et nous faire
vomir
dans des événements
d'évangélisation
des messages
qui pour plus
théologiquement précis
qu'ils soient
semblent n'avoir
aucun intérêt réel
dans l'âme
de l'entour
et le pouteur
et ces choses
sont tellement perçues
est-ce que nous avons
un intérêt réel
pour les saluts
des âmes
qui nous entourent
est-ce qu'on se sent mal
quand on a eu
l'occasion
d'avoir des parents
qui sont venus chercher
ces enfants
chez nous
quand ils ont joué
avec nos enfants
ils ne sont pas convertis
et on n'a pas
fait des efforts
pour prolonger
un peu la conversation
parce qu'en ayant parti
vous savez
mon séjour au Brésil
était tellement
bénissant
en termes d'évangélisation
cette fois
surprenante
mais quand même
je suis parti là
avec un poids
dans mon coeur
quand je n'ai pas vu
toutes les personnes
que je lui aurais aimé voir
je n'ai pas pu partager
l'évangile
avec les personnes
chères pour moi
pour qui j'ai pris
et donc
pour rentrer plus
dans ce qui est
de plus important
une évangélisation
efficace
a lieu
lorsque Christ
se manifeste
par un témoignage
rempli
de l'autorité
du Saint-Esprit
à travers
la proclamation
de la parole
de Dieu
pour faire plus court
Christ
doit être proclamé
dans la puissance
du Saint-Esprit
selon l'écriture
une évangélisation
biblique
telle comme celle
de Philippe
elle est ancrée
dans la parole
c'est très bien
d'être équipé
de comprendre
la vision des mondes
de l'intellecteur
essayer de déconstruire
ses erreurs
de faire
l'apologète
apologétique
pardon
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
la simplicité
avec laquelle
l'évangile était prêché
pour des hommes
même très sophistiqués
comme Philippe
originaire
des cultures
grecques
romaines
ou même
l'apôtre Paul
reconnu
historiquement
comme l'une
des mentalités
ou des pensées
les plus brillantes
indépendamment
des fois
ou des religions
ces écrits
sont tenus
comme
les pièces
les plus magistrales
de l'histoire
un homme
qui a été
enseigné
cultivé
dans la culture
grecque
romaine
hébraïque
avec les meilleurs
professeurs
et qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit
j'ai décidé
de rien savoir entre vous
à part Christ
et celui-ci
crucifié
donc Christ
proclamé
dans la puissance
de Saint-Esprit
selon l'écriture
on est
devant
un petit morceau
des écritures
qui sera
utilisé
par Philippe
pour partager
l'évangile
donc
laissons pour nous
ne transférez
jamais
votre incrédulité
envers votre ami
je pense
qu'il n'est pas
prêt
à entendre
une heure
déni
des prédications
je préfère
plutôt
faire quelque chose
chez moi
l'amener en groupe
des maisons
Dieu a dit à Moïse
allez
ils vont te croire
et Moïse dit
mais s'ils ne croient pas
c'est que j'ai dit
ne méprisez jamais
l'opportunité
d'une personne
d'être exposée
à la proclamation
de la vérité
c'est pas toujours
qu'on aura la possibilité
de trouver une personne
pour évangéliser
qui soit en train
de lire la Bible
et voilà pourquoi
l'église
à plusieurs reprises
est les lieux
les plus évangélisiques
qui ont pu
s'amener une personne
car c'est sur la base
de la parole
des dieux
que nous sommes en train
de proclamer
l'évangile
l'évangélisation
est annoncée
des bouches
grandes ouvertes
l'évangélisation
biblique
est une évangélisation
annoncée
des bouches
grandes ouvertes
elle lui dit
verset 35
alors Philippe
ouvrant la bouche
cette expression
elle signifie
conviction
autorité
témoin
en témoin
il parle
avec conviction
car il a vu
quelque chose
de magistral
c'est vrai
pour lui
de sortir
dans sa prière
de la présence
du dieu vivant
et de ne pas
craindre les hommes
c'est pas
qu'il soit
courageux
devant les mondes
c'est juste qu'il sait
à qui il doit craindre
et si la présence
des dieux
elle est plus fraîche
pour lui
l'éminence
de leur destruction
est plus réelle
que l'éminence
de leur persécution
envers moi
et donc par amour
revêtue
d'autorité
des convictions
je dois proclamer
l'évangile
pour leur bien
bouche
grande ouverte
l'évangilation
biblique
est ancrée
dans l'autorité
et les contenus
de la parole
de Dieu
donc le texte
nous dit ici
que les passages
verset 32
de l'écriture
sangulier
qu'est-ce que cela
veut dire
les passages
de l'écriture
c'est car
il n'est pas
tout simplement
en train de citer
les passages
des haïs
un livre
d'un prophète
il est en train
de citer
un passage
qui est un morceau
d'un texte
sangulier
composé par
plusieurs livres
inspirés par Dieu
c'est-à-dire
c'est un seul livre
à la fin des comptes
car il y a un seul auteur
c'est Dieu lui-même
l'écritur
écrit
sang
mais pourquoi
dans les sanguliers
car tous les canons
sont sous
l'inspiration divine
et l'intentionnalité
des dieux
pour nous communiquer
les vérités
à propos de lui-même
et de comment nous pouvons
nous réconcilier avec lui
donc l'écriture
qu'il lisait
et donc la citation
des haïs
et quand on arrive
au Bécis 25
Philippe
ouvrant la bouche
et commençant
par ses passages
vous êtes avec moi
lui annonça
la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
donc qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
quand on fait l'évolution
utiliser les passages bibliques
pour annoncer
la bonne nouvelle Jésus
nous n'avons aucune autorité
de nous-mêmes
il n'y a aucun gain réel
dans toutes nos stratégies
d'évangélisation
si elles ne sont pas
ancrées
dans les écritures
c'est pas par les divertissements
qu'on va tromper
la personne envers la foi
c'est par l'annonce
de l'évangile
selon les écritures
la base de notre autorité
est la parole de Dieu
et voilà pourquoi
nous pouvons parler
avec conviction
nous sommes des perroquets
maintenant dans les bons sens
des dieux
on n'est pas
qui c'est qu'on a reçu
lui annonça
la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
donc les contenus
et l'autorité
de la parole de Dieu
ensuite
l'évangélisation
elle est
christocentrique
donc le texte nous dit
le eunuque
pose la question
est-ce que les prophètes
parlent de lui-même
remarquez bien
la sensibilité de savoir
qu'il avait quelque chose
qui allait au-delà du prophète
et c'est clairement
le Messie
où il parle
de quelqu'un d'autre
et donc
quelle est la réponse
de Philippe
c'est démontrer
que ces passages
tout comme tout autre passage
des écritures
pointent envers Jésus-Christ
d'ailleurs
c'est
l'une des évidences
les plus
irréfutables
à propos
de l'inspiration
des écritures
c'est la quantité
plus de 350
passages
du Nouveau Testament
sont des accomplissements
des prophéties
spécifiques
sur les crises
de l'Ancien
et si on ajoute
cette réalité
aux symbolologies
de l'Ancien Testament
tous les symboles
qui sont accomplis
en Christ
nous comprenons
qu'il y a
un nombre
infini
de liaisons
entre l'Ancien Testament
et l'accomplissement
du Christ
comment
4000 ans
3000 ans
1000 ans
700 ans
comme le cas
de cette prophétie
avant le Christ
la chose était décrite
avec la précision
avec laquelle
elle est décrite
la seule explication
c'est que Dieu
lorsqu'il est
en train de donner
en prophétie
il n'est pas tout simplement
en train de prévoir
les futurs
il est en train
de communiquer
ce qu'il fera
lui-même
c'est sa souveraineté
qui assure
sa prévoyance
et pas l'inverse
et donc ici
nous voyons
cette description
et voilà pourquoi
Christ
il est
non seulement
les centres
des écritures
l'écriture
n'est pas à propos
de moi
elle est à propos
du Christ
Christ au centre
mais Christ
comme la clé
d'interprétation
principale
de tous les passages
des écritures
comment interpréter
les haïs
avec l'aide
du Christ
voilà pourquoi
les mouvements
pour nous
c'est
les privilèges
de pouvoir
commencer par l'évangile
et ensuite
protégé par Christ
n'est pas tombé
dans les erreurs
d'interprétation
des judaïsants
l'évangile
elle est donc
Christocentrique
mais l'évangile
elle est aussi
doctrinaire
elle est doctrinaire
et qu'est-ce qu'on
veut dire par là
c'est que nous sommes
devant
l'un des textes
les plus simples
mais mon enfant
peut comprendre
comment
cet agneux
ou cette brébie
évoquée ici
représente
l'expiation
de nos péchés
représente
les crises
qui sont venus
pour être crucifiés
à notre place
mais mon enfant
Dieu a fait exprès
et de manière
très intentionnelle
peut-être pas
quand on est en train
de contempler
tout simplement
les fonctionnements
du temple
de la Pâque
et l'Ancien Testament
mais certainement
après avoir
ce qui s'est passé
avec Christ
comprendre
comment cette brébie
représente-elle
les Messies
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc c'est doctrinaire
dans le sens où
la symbologie biblique
et la narrative biblique
et les faits historiques
principaux
que la Bible
cherche
à nous expliquer
ont toujours
un objectif
très clair
de faire
des déclarations
les oracles
de Dieu
c'est-à-dire
ce sont des déclarations
intentionnelles
de la part des dieux
des vérités
absolues
bien définies
et claires
pour que personne
avec une bonne intention
soit capable
de mettre en question
donc ce texte par exemple
il est doctrinaire
car c'est impossible
de contempler ce texte
à la lumière du Christ
et arriver
à point de dire
que Christ
était tout simplement
un exemple
d'altruisme
un pacificateur
activiste
un homme
injustement
assassiné
un bon exemple
impossible
et donc
ici nous sommes
devant
des faits
et des vérités
des déclarations
inspirées
qui révèlent
l'intentionnalité
des dieux
si nous sommes
en désaccord
à propos
de certaines vérités
bibliques
capitales
claires
nous pouvons
être tous
avoir tous
tort par rapport
à ça
ou un seul
avoir raison
car la Bible
a un seul auteur
et si elle a un seul auteur
elle n'a qu'une
bonne interprétation
vous êtes avec moi
est-ce que
les textes
parlent
d'un prophète
non
les textes
parlent
de Jésus
et quel Jésus
le Jésus
qui est dans l'histoire
a accompli
ces textes
de manière
indubitable
c'est un Jésus
avec une identité
bien définie
y compris
définie
par ces textes
vous voyez
notre foi
elle est basée
dans des faits
historiques
avec une signification
précise
et l'évangélisation
est doctrinaire
dans ce sens
qui est
les Christ
qui sauve
comment
son oeuvre
a été faite
de manière
à être efficace
et suffisante
pour me sauver
et comment
peux-je participer
à ces saluts
ce sont des questions
cruciales
par rapport auxquelles
si nous n'avons pas
la bonne réponse
définie
précise
nous ne pouvons pas
être sauvés
tout simplement
et donc
nous pouvons imaginer
comment Philippe
à partir de ces textes
comment
sans par ces passages
a pu annoncer
la bonne nouvelle
donc au moins
nous en tant que chrétiens
on doit être capable
d'expliquer ces doctrines
essentielles
de l'évangile
sinon
l'évangélisation
n'a pas lieu
et quelles sont
les doctrines
qu'on trouve ici
avec clarté
en toute évidence
verset 32
les passages
l'écriture
qu'il lisait
était celui-ci
il a été mené
comme une brébie
à la boucherie
quel est le contexte
les ailes 53
les léonucs
qui est intéressé
par ces passages
en revenant
de la pentecôte
50 jours après
là
Pâques
et dans cette dernière Pâques
qui a été
exécuté
comme une brébie
Jésus-Christ
de Nazareth
il a été
mené
comme une brébie
à la boucherie
donc ça évoque
la Pâques
quelle est la doctrine
pour nous
dans la compréhension
basique
fondamentale
d'un israélite
on transférait
notre coupabilité
envers
une brébie
qui devrait
être
sans tâche
parfaite
sans maladie
donc quelle est la doctrine
pour nous
pour vous aider
avec un terme
théologique
c'est
la justification
substitutive
qui comprend
cette innocence
qui qualifie
les seignes de Christ
pour nous représenter
car il était
innocent
capable
donc
de nous
imputer
de nous offrir
son innocence
son obéissance
parfaite
sa perfection
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc à la croix
à cette Pâques
les Christ
il va prendre
son innocence
et se sacrifier
pour pouvoir
communiquer
à nous
pécheurs
répentis
l'obéissance
qui nous qualifie
envers la réconciliation
avec Dieu
Dieu peut
me traiter
comme si je n'avais
jamais péché
comme si j'étais
innocent
parfaitement
obéissant
car je suis
revêtu
de l'innocence
du Christ
mais il a été
aussi
une vraie vie
à la boucherie
car il y a
cette double dette
on doit
à Dieu
une obéissance
une vie d'amour
qu'on n'arrive pas
à vivre
mais nous méritons
aussi
la punition
proportionnelle
exacte
par rapport
à nos péchés
et lorsqu'on comprend
que cette proportion
est la proportion
de la sainteté
de Dieu
la dignité
nous ne pouvons pas
souffrir assez
et voilà pourquoi
l'enfer
est éternel
donc Christ
à la croix
il était en train
de souffrir
comme un brébis
à la boucherie
car on a été
exposé
à la torture
la plus développée
possiblement
de l'histoire
l'intérêt
de prolonger
la souffrance
car les personnes
pouvaient vivre
sur cette croix
4-5 jours
en souffrance extrême
avec ses bras
étirés
les tendons
touchés
par les clous
et une sensation
de pouvoir
à tout moment
mettre les pieds
par terre
sauf que
à cause de l'auteur
qu'il mettait
les personnes
à chaque fois
qu'on essayait
d'émettre
les pieds
par terre
on souffrait
aussi énormément
au niveau
des tendons
des jambes
et à un moment donné
les personnes
étaient mortes
par asphyxie
par l'incapacité
de continuer
à s'élever
la poitrine
pour respirer
et donc
comme un brébier
la boucherie
nous montre clairement
que Christ
à la croix
il était en train
de souffrir
une punition extrême
!
Sauf que
cette punition
n'était pas
tout simplement
la punition physique
il était diffamé
craché
c'était une souffrance
émotionnelle
car dans les jacques
quand il anticipait ça
il a transpiré
du sang déjà
mais la pire
des souffrances
c'est celle
qui est évoquée
par la prochaine doctrine
c'est cette doctrine
de la soumission
volontaire
de l'expiation
à la croix
qui a provoqué
la séparation
entre Dieu le père
et Dieu le fils
et comme un agneux
disons
moué
devant celui
que l'étant
il n'a point
ouvert la bouche
et le 23 nous dit clairement
il n'a plus
au père
de l'écraser
c'est pas un plaisir
qui veut
qui veut signifier
les plaisirs
dans l'acte en soi
!
et c'est cette décision
souveraine des dieux
sachant qu'à travers
cette oeuvre
les biens
suprêmes
auraient lieu
et la dignité du Christ
serait encore même
plus élevée
même si elle était déjà
en finie
en mystère
mais la réalité
c'est que
les pères
et les fils
étaient volontairement
d'accord
car il n'y a pas
la possibilité
d'une expiation réelle
sinon ça serait
un abus
ok
parental
les pères
qui obligent
les fils
à souffrir
à notre place
les pères
et les fils
étaient volontairement
d'accord
et les pères
et les fils
ont souffert
énormément
avec séparation
à midi
lorsqu'on voyait
pleinement
les soleils
les ténèbres
sont vaines
et la Bible
décrit
les fils
des dieux
comme s'ils
étaient
les plaques
de matin
les soleils
qui s'élèvent
et la faveur
des dieux
les plaisirs
envers nous
est représentée
la satisfaction
des dieux
envers nous
comme la lumière
que les seigneurs
fassent
luire sa face
et donc
la lumière
elle représente
cette béatitude
qui trouve
son aspect
suprême
dans la communion
éternelle
entre les pères
et les fils
au-dedans
de la trinité
les fils
l'objet suprême
d'une relation
d'amour
digne de toute
adoration
à cause
de ses perfections
la relation
la plus douce
possible
et les pères
également
la même chose
pour les fils
donc une seule
goutte
des sensations
de séparation
pour ces êtres
qui trouvent
leur béatitude
naturelle
dans cette relation
c'est déjà pire
que
mille en fer
et la réalité
c'est qu'à la croix
le Christ
il est mort
dans trois heures
non car
il a souffert
plus physiquement
car les seules choses
ou les seuls moments
où le Christ
va couper
son silence
en tant qu'ébré
bimouette
n'est pas
devant
les injustes
qui sont en train
de l'étendre
mais c'est devant
la souffrance
pire
qu'il est en train
de traverser
mon Dieu
pourquoi
m'as-tu
abandonné
donc le fils
ne peut
qui
nous représenter
comme totalement
acceptable
devant Dieu
il n'y a rien
qui manque
dans cette oeuvre
car Dieu
peut nous traiter
tout librement
comme son fils
bien-aimé
car un jour
il n'a pas
épargné
son fils
il l'a traité
complètement
comme s'il était
non seulement
l'un d'entre nous
mais tous ceux
qui étaient abominables
aux yeux des dieux
à cause de ses péchés
en prenant en compte
chacun de nos péchés
et de nos transgressions
donc la doctrine
de la soumission
volontaire du fils
qui est très importante
pour que ça soit
une oeuvre réelle
de rédemption
il y a ici aussi
la doctrine
de l'innocence
du Christ
dans son nomination
son jugement
a été
lévé
c'est-à-dire
c'était clair
pour tous
qui c'était
un acte
d'injustice
extrême
et donc
qui met en évidence
davantage
son innocence
parfaite
il y avait cet endroit
et sa postérité
qui la dépendra
car sa vie
a été rétranchée
de la terre
et donc ici
c'est l'un des points
les plus glorieux
c'est au moins
trois doctrines
importantes ici
les scandales
de la croix
d'abord
car c'est impossible
pour un homme
encore accroché
à ce monde
de reconnaître
que Christ
était le vrai Seigneur
et c'était particulièrement
impossible
aux juifs
d'imaginer
que leur rédempteur
qui devrait venir
pour
restaurer
les royaumes
sur terre
d'Israël
et qui est mort
de cette manière
si humiliant
sur la croix
donc l'humiliation
du Christ
la question ici
c'est
sa génération
ce qui peut signifier
sa nature
sa vraie généalogie
et donc
le scandale
est évident ici
car il empêche
l'homme naturel
de reconnaître
Christ
comme le vrai
fils de Dieu
à nouveau
on revient
à l'importance
absolue
de l'oeuvre
du Saint-Esprit
pour franchir
avec l'aveuglement
naturel
de l'homme rébelle
dans le texte
il dit
qui a déchiffré
qui la dépendra
dans l'orignal
c'est plutôt
qui a déchiffré
qui serait capable
de pendre
sa génération
ses cadres
du Christ
placardé
à la croix
humilié
craché
vaincu
apparemment
et de dire
en effet
c'est là
exactement
le moment
il a été
en train de vaincre
c'est là
exactement
le moment
il a montré
sa suprême
noblesse
en se rabaissant
jusqu'à la mort
et la mort
des croix
afin de nous élever
à la présence
du Père
à la dignité
des fils
et donc ici
il y a la doctrine
du scandale
de la croix
mais aussi
la doctrine
de la double
nature du Christ
car les textes
ayant ces mots
très beaux
et les passages
des Haïts
qui parlent
de ces deux aspects
dans un premier moment
qui a cogité
à propos
de sa lignée
qui a pris
le temps
d'aller
vers la généalogie
plus tard
qu'on a eu
des Matthieu
ou des Luc
pour dire
il était véritablement
les Messies
les fils des dieux
donc la double
nature du Christ
qui est nécessaire
fondamentale
et qui implique
à partir de là
dans l'essence
virginale du Christ
des doctrines
qu'il faut croire
pour se considérer
vraiment chrétien
mais ça parle aussi
de sa postérité
car les passages
des Esprit 3
nous assure
qu'à cause
du travail
de son âme
il rassasera
ses regards
par les connaissances
de mon serviteur
les justifiera
beaucoup d'hommes
il se chargera
de leur uniquité
c'est pourquoi
je lui donnerai
sa part avec les grands
et il partagera
les boutons
avec les puissants
parce qu'il s'est livré
lui-même à la mort
et qu'il était soumis
pardon
mis au nombre
des malfacteurs
parce qu'il a porté
les péchés
de beaucoup d'hommes
et qu'il a intercédé
pour les coupables
et la Bible dit
en Esaïe aussi
que Dieu allait
faire prospérer
sa postérité
et pleurant
gérer
ces jours
c'est-à-dire
l'assurance
de la continuité
du roi
homme de Christ
de la conversion
des âmes
vient notamment
par le fait
qu'il était
humilié
de manière
substitutive
jusqu'à la croix
et qu'il a été
ressuscité
et élevé
afin de faire
son roi homme
continuer d'avancer
et quels sont les résultats
les résultats
dans les passages
nous montrent
que par
cette proclamation
Christ
a été
dans l'original
dans les versets
pour conclure
la fin du verset
Philippe lui
annonça la bonne nouvelle
de Jésus
ou plutôt
dans l'original
il lui
évangélisa
Christ
qu'est-ce que cela veut dire
qu'à la fin des comptes
au fur et à mesure
qu'on est en train
de présenter
les vérités
les doctrines
de manière biblique
en présentant Christ
nous ne sommes pas
qu'en train de parler
à propos de Jésus
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
il est
lui-même
en train de se faire
présent
et de se présenter
à l'intellecteur
pour les sauver
Christ est évangélisé
Christ
est non seulement
annoncé
comme la bonne nouvelle
mais Christ
il est
la bonne nouvelle
en lui-même
de manière personnelle
et voilà pourquoi
pendant qu'on essaye
avec tous nos efforts
de toucher
à la gloire
au mystère
à la grandeur
de cette oeuvre
de rédemption
nous sommes
dans l'attente
et dans la ferme confiance
comme disait
l'apôtre Paul
qui pendant
qu'on vous proclame
et on vous en supplie
de vous réconcilier
avec Dieu
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
lui-même
est en train de vous parler
personnellement
en vous appelant
à la répentance
à embrasser
lui-même
comme votre représentant
devant les tribunales
des dieux
et c'est comme ça
que nous approchons
du Christ
et c'est comme ça
que l'évangélisation
a lieu
et l'efficacité
comme on verra
le dimanche prochain
se porte vers
la conversion
de cet homme
qui peut déclarer
lui-même
je crois
que le Seigneur Jésus Christ
est vraiment
le fils des dieux
et c'est comme ça